one of the largest blood providers is
taking over the las vegas ballpark today
and tomorrow vi talent is holding a big
blood drive and bianca holman is live
there this morning
to tell you how you can donate and be
part of it good morning bianca
hey good morning sherry good morning
everybody at home we are at the las
vegas ballpark in the play studio and
this
location here has been turned into
vitalin donation center
and to tell us more about the blood
donation happening today i'm joined by
brittany from vital and so tell us what
made you all come out here to the
ballpark to do two days of a blood drive
you know we're so grateful for our
sponsor cox communications you know
since march with business closures we've
had to cancel over 200 blood drives so
we're just grateful that the las vegas
ballpark is hosting two days of blood
drives
yeah so i understand that when people
decide to donate they gotta sign up and
advance support
there is uh the antibody testing that
they can get yes every blood donation
will come with an antibody test and
you'll get
your results in three weeks and with
those results if you get positive
antibody test results you have the
opportunity
to help cover 19 patients with your
antibodies by becoming a convalescent
plasma donor
and i understand one donation can help
three hospital patients
that's a lot for just an hour out of
your day but if there's somebody sitting
at home that's
on the fence on should i sign up should
i not sign up what would you say to them
you know we had a local family come out
recently the urbina family
a family of seven that recovered from
covid19 and they made it their mission
to help recover covid19 patients so they
can get
better and well out of the hospital
again and so i think about that family
and those in our community who have
recovered or who are healthy and well
and eligible to donate blood
take an hour out of your day to help
save lives it doesn't take much time i
know of course you all have safety for
measures in place of social distancing
you have to wear your mask they are
taking the temperature checks
so again this is a great cause to help
people in our community people who are
involved in crashes
people who are cancer patients
moms who are experiencing complications
after after birth so this is going to
help somebody you know in our community
and you can
actually sign up in advance the
appointments you are taking for today
and tomorrow
spaces are filling up quickly but you
can go on to buy talent.org right
absolutely by talent.org to make an
appointment reporting live from the las
vegas ballpark bianca holman
eight news now all right bianca thank
you very much